so the reports are the joel greenberg  friend of matt gates in the gates gate  scandal  has reached an agreement with  authorities and has entered into some  sort of plea agreement greenberg's  lawyer fritz sheller said on the  courthouse steps  i'm sure matt gates is not feeling very  comfortable today all right  now it's not clear if this is a plea  agreement where you just simply agree to  cooperate in exchange for a light  reduction in sentence to make things  easier on the prosecutor  or if this is a cooperation agreement  where you agree to cooperate against  bigger fish in this case that could  probably only mean matt gates  so we'll see if matt gates really is  feeling uncomfortable and we'll see if  we see him  in court